bonjour nadège alors quelques tensions
mais maintenant retour au calme
[Musique]
absolument un erreur vous le voyez
peut-être derrière moi les gie les
jeunes viennent d'arriver place de la
république où ils tiennent et d'un
attendre quelques minutes en hommage
la manifestation
en soutien au peuple colombien qui a
manifesté cet après midi en soutien à la
population colombienne qui le pays
depuis dix jours est le théâtre de
violents affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre au
moins 24 personnes ont perdu la vie et
huit cent cinquante autres ont été
blessées dans ces affrontements colombie
donc on voit l'aller chez les jeunes ont
tenu et bien apporter leur soutien et à
manifester ne serait ce que quelques
minutes
avec ces manifestants le colombien alors
la situation est là elle s'est tendu il
ya à peu près une heure un peu plus
d'une heure en rue de la roquette ans
lorsque des agents de la brav brigade de
répression de l'action violente un
motorisé sont intervenus pour
interpeller un manifestant manifestants
qui étaient visiblement ciblé puisqu'il
a tenté un peu nu le long comme terreau
pelé et donc et au cours de cette
interpellation à ses agents de la brad
des biens ont blessé un des gilets
jaunes ont matraqué certains d'entre eux
et certains ont été les biens ont touché
par des sprays de gaz lacrymogènes dont
quoi vous vous imaginez accès
manifestants et bienfaiteur en colère
ils ont refusé que le cortège avance
progresse pendant plus d'une demi-heure
pour montrer leur mécontentement
vis-à-vis de cette action violente de l
as bras donc pour l'instant
le cortège a finalement poursuivi son
parcours
la situation s'est détendue mais bon
voilà à noter quelques qu'on soit lors
de ce rassemblement
au début on début de parcours nous
sommes avec l'homme ç'a pris 9 night
vous êtes co déclarons de cette
manifestation aujourd'hui
racontez-moi un peu comment s'est
déroulée cette interpellation tout à
l'heure d'un manifestant qui a provoqué
de vives tensions au sein au sein du
cortège
bah en fait donc c'est comme tous les
samedis au rassemblement de la ji des
jaunes pour une justice sociale et
fiscale
on a commencé de ce rassemblement le
départ du cortège tout se passait très
bien
il n'y avait pas de tension il n'y avait
pas d'animosité c'était des chances
étaient de revendications et il ya eu
une charge à un moment sans sommation
sans rien vous l'expliquez comment ça se
fait que ce manifestants étaient ciblés
en particulier
bah écoutez moi je pars du principe que
même s'ils ont une interpellation à
faire il ya une méthodologie à avoir
rentré dans une foule pour intervenait
alors que justement il ya eu au début du
rassemblement j'aurais pu très bien la
perte mais pourquoi attendre à un
croisement rentrer dans une foule sans
sommation enfin il ya un moment
certains disent qu'il était sous le coup
d'une interdiction de manifester vous
avez des infos là j'étais je suis sa
conjointe donc ça tombe très bien
oui effectivement lors d'une marche des
libertés qui s'était passé à ici il
avait été interpellé il a été acquitté
et en fait ça fait déjà deux fois ci une
fiche en fait qu'ils ouvrent qu'ils ne
mettent pas un jour voilà donc en fait
il se donne un motif à chaque fois pour
l'interpeller alors qu'il a été acquitté
voilà on peut parler de interpellations
abusives ou pas oui on peut parler
d'interpellations à abusive et avec une
sucrine méthodologie abusive
voilà on peut interpeller les ya des
méthodes d'interpellation je pense pas
qu'elle soit très conventionnel on a eu
un lien avec la préfecture qui nous
expliquait que c'est pas le métier qui
donnait l'ordre
c'était la salle d'à côté il faut
m'expliquer a un moment faut assumer les
ordres qu'on donne là c'est
incompréhensible n'y a pas eu une
sommation
paris le mouvement de gilet jaune a
débuté il ya 30 mois
vous avez manifesté quasiment tous les
samedis même si elle traîne à un moment
lorsqu'il ya eu des confinement est ce
que ça vaut le coup de continuer à
manifester 30 ans après le début du
mouvement parce qu'on al'impression bon
vous n'êtes pas forcément entendus par
le gouvernement
et pourtant vous continuez de sortir
voilà justement c'est leur jeu ils
veulent que cette contestation
s'éteignent de toute façon s'il n'avait
pas cette appréhension là on n'aurait
pas un effectif de possibles de deux
postes de police aussi conséquents et en
est le temps pendant ces trente mois là
on a eu une répression inimaginable des
mutilations des gens qui ont perdu des
modes et des membres ça fait perdre bien
sûr que ça fait mort en marge du
mouvement des accidents les rejoigne sa
fenêtre comme le premier jour bep/j les
jaunes on n'oublie pas cette femme qui
était un rond point et qui a été fauché
par une voiture dès le premier jour
voilà et cc c'est pour eux qu'il faut
continuer bien sûr c'est pour eux qu'il
faut continuer et puis c'est pour tous
ceux qui cherchent quand même avoir une
justice sociale et fiscale
on demande
la violence à un moment où il faut
savoir admettre ses torts des deux côtés
et on avancera les cette politique de la
peur ça ne fonctionne pas cette
politique de la répression non plus à 30
mois je suis désolé oui effectivement
pourquoi on est encore dans la rue mais
si on rentre alors on oublie les morts
on oublie les mutilés merci et sabrina à
nice rappelle que vous êtes co
déclarante de ce rassemblement vous
l'avez entendu à l image de la côte
déclarante de ce rassemblement de chez
les jeunes aujourd'hui bien ils sont
déterminés à continuer à manifester
ne serait-ce que quand un hommage pour
les victimes de ce mouvement des filets
jaunes qui ont donc perdu la vie ou
alors qu'ils ont été mutilés lors de
manifestations violentes
merci à beaucoup à nadège pour toutes
ces précisions